[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour le journal de tv 78 bienvenue dans
cette édition du mardi 21 septembre
voici les titres
le procès s'ouvre demain à versailles
six personnes comparaissent devant la
justice pour l'instant dit du chapiteau
de chanteloup les vignes dans la nuit du
2 au 3 novembre 2019 la structure lieux
culturels apprécié dans la commune était
entièrement détruite par les flammes
la soirée avait été émaillée également
de violence à l'encontre des forces de
l'ordre
bâtir des territoires de confiance le
nom de cette journée dédiée à la
sécurité numérique dans les
collectivités elle s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui au théâtre de saint quentin
en yvelines organisée par
l'agglomération et le j4 nous en parlons
avec notre invité bertrand coquard vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis direction le vésinet à la fin de
cette édition commune où elle réside et
joséphine baker pendant 18 ans les
jardins de sa demeure la ville à
beauchêne s'ouvrait exceptionnellement
au public c'était à l'occasion des
journées européennes du patrimoine
yann arthus bertrand qui s'expose dans
des églises yvelinoise c'est également
dans ce journal et on en parle tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
les incendiaires du chapiteau de
chanteloup-les-vignes devant la justice
à partir de ce mercredi pendant deux
jours le procès pour lequel la
municipalité notamment se porte partie
civile va se dérouler devant la cour
correctionnelle et le tribunal pour
enfants de versailles une audience
quasiment deux ans après les faits la
destruction de ce lieu culturel les
précisions avec nicolas landry
l'incendié avait été mis dans le
département des yvelines dans la nuit du
2 au 3 novembre 2019 le chapiteau de
l'arche lieu d'initiation aux arts du
cirque et de la danse était détruit
totalement par les flammes à
chanteloup-les-vignes pertes matérielles
chiffré à plus d'un million d'euros
causée par cet acte volontaire près de
deux ans après les faits six personnes
comparaissent à partir de ce mercredi
devant la justice à versailles cinq
personnes sont renvoyées devant le
tribunal correctionnel et 1 des mises en
cause a été renvoyé devant le tribunal
pour enfants puisqu'il était mineur au
moment des faits alors ils sont renvoyés
des chefs de destruction volontaire par
incendie donc plusieurs années de prison
également des violences assez importante
sur des forces de l'ordre le chapiteau
s'était embrasée lors de scènes de
violences urbaines qui avaient touché le
quartier de la noé vers 21h30 le 2
novembre 2019 les policiers sont appelés
pour un feu de poubelle les forces de
l'ordre doivent alors essuyé pendant
plusieurs heures des jets de pierres et
de cocktails molotov ainsi que des tirs
de mortier ces événements aux fêtes se
sont inscrits eux à une période c'était
la fin de l'année 2019 où il y avait eu
plusieurs événements de violences
urbaines dans le département des
yvelines dont qui avait marqué
effectivement de façon très importante
cette époque là depuis le coc vide aussi
est passé entre temps ces événements ne
se sont pas reproduits et bien sûr ce
n'est pas ce qu'on souhaite le site va
renaître de ses cendres un espace
culturel est en cours de construction en
lieu et place de l'ancienne arch quant à
la compagnie d contraire l'association
qui occupaient les lieux elle a pu
reprendre ses activités sur la dalle
voisine où un nouveau chapiteau a été
dressé avec le soutien de la région ile
de france le procès va durer deux jours
les 22 et 23 septembre la justice
pourrait statuer tout de suite ou mettre
sa décision en délibéré
dans l'actualité judiciaire également
12000 euros damende requis par le
procureur de la république à l'encontre
de jean messia est le polémiste et
chroniqueur comparaissait ce lundi
devant le tribunal de versailles pour
injures publiques elles ont ce février
dernier sur son compte twitter il
estimait que les islamistes avaient je
cite un ami dans les yvelines en se
référant au préfet jean jacques brot un
tweet survenue en pleine affaire du
professeur de philosophie didier le nay
rattrape et jean jacques brot avait
apporté plein de contre l'ancien délégué
du rassemblement national le tribunal de
versailles rendra sa décision le 18
octobre prochain
bâtir des territoires de confiance je
vous en parlais dans les titres c'était
cette matinée de conférences proposé au
théâtre de saint quentin en yvelines
organisée par l'agglomération et le j4
le groupement des industries françaises
de défense et de sécurité terrestre et
aéro terrestre au menu de cet événement
les technologies du numérique au service
des collectivités locales nicolas landry
et patrick jacques de dixmude
une cartographie du quartier du stade de
france avec différents types de données
le principe de cette plateforme digitale
de sécurité développé par thales un
groupe industriel de défense j'ai
prendre l'incident type agression quand
je clique dessus j'ai accès à une
fenêtre qui va s'ouvrir up ici j'ai mon
incident avec un environnement qui a été
donnée est une procédure à suivre par
type d'incident en passant d'un accident
données ont fait une type de procédé
cette solution est conçue sur le site de
vélizy elle est destinée aux
collectivités locales et aux sites
sensibles l'idée est d'assurer la
sécurité à partir des données collectées
par des capteurs la plateforme a pour
objectif de fédérer les données qui sont
les données et les sous systèmes qui
sont déjà disposés dans les villes afin
d'apporter un tableau de bord une vision
concrète de ce qui se passe dans la vie
ça peut être une caméra de vidéo
protection
mais ça peut aussi être un détecteur de
bruit c'est ensemble là va permettre de
dire il ya un bruit anormal à un moment
donné dans la journée est-ce que c'est
pas un chantier pirate est ce que c'est
pas une fête où est-ce que c'est pas un
incident qui s'est produit plusieurs
technologies ont été présentés en
parallèle des tables rondes organisées
dans le cadre de la matinée bâtir des
territoires de confiance des échanges
entre des industriels des élus locaux et
des représentants de l'état sur la place
du numérique dans l'activité des
collectivités locales
là c'était de voir comment
finalement au travers d'outils on
expérimentera au plus près des
territoires donc en lien avec les maires
les présidents d'exécutifs locaux
pourront les frais partagés à nos
concitoyens pour instiller ce qu'on
recherche c'est finalement du numérique
de confiance et on a besoin pour que
cette confiance ne s'installe que ces
projets d'expérimentation soient portés
par les collectivités locales parmi les
projets innovants menés par une
collectivité il ya le commissariat
d'agglomération du futur un outil
technologique qui devrait voir le jour à
elancourt en 2024 et pour continuer à
parler de ce sujet bertrand coq harnes a
rejoint en plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué à la
smart cities à l'énergie et à
l'éclairage public première question
déjà que retenez-vous des échanges de ce
matin des échanges très constructifs
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales on a pu voir on
était des fois soumis un petit peu aérée
d attaque de cyber
rançon donc effectivement donc c'était
intéressant de pouvoir discuter de tout
ce qu'on pouvait leur apporter comme
aide concrètement suite suite à ça donc
et puis beaucoup dé change basé sur sur
l'éthique aussi parce que la notion de
numérique c'est la notion de partage de
données et comment on pouvait construire
aussi un territoire de confiance et
aussi la notion de la donne et comment
les usagers pouvaient nous faire
confiance en gardant leurs données alors
on l'a vu dans le sujet l'agglomération
est engagée dans l'innovation
technologique du numérique on a parlé de
ce projet du commissariat du futur elle
encourt en quoi justement il s'inscrit
dans cette stratégie de l'agglomération
aujourd'hui on sait que nous allons
recevoir on a la chance d'avoir quatre
sites pour les jeux olympiques et on
souhaiterait effectivement avoir un
commissariat qui soit totalement
avec des outils numériques qui
permettent d'avoir la meilleure sécurité
possible aujourd'hui avec usage de
drones et autres et c'est vraiment
important pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens de faire appel à toutes
sortes de techniques et bien sûr le
numérique en fait partie donc par
exemple l'événement d'aujourd'hui ça
rejoint un peu cet objectif c'est d'être
initiateurs de parler de ces idées qui
peuvent se développer dans le futur sur
le territoire oui il ya eu au delà du
commissariat du futur il ya eu 2 2
annonce assez importante quand on parle
de cyber sécurité
on parle aussi de comment on peut
identifier la menace et comment on peut
la traiter donc ces deux choses qui dans
un jargon on parle de 2 socke et de
certes stock c'est effectivement la
possibilité d'avoir des experts qui
peuvent intervenir auprès des pme ou
intervenir auprès des collectivités pour
identifier une menace et pouvoir
effectivement la traiter c'est la
fameuse caserne cyber caserne que porte
saint quentin en yvelines à travers un
projet porté aussi par la région et donc
on va parler dans un instant juste
d'abord quelles sont les technologies
déployées à à saint quentin en yvelines
sur le territoire dans le cadre de la
ville intelligente ce qu'on appelle la
smart cities quelles sont elles alors
elles sont multiples les skis le plus
abouti aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr la
gestion des éclairages un intelligent
dans lequel on a pu penser au volet
cybersécurité aussi puisqu'on a
développé avec tout un pack airbus
notamment et d'autres
industriel un pack qui nous permet
effectivement d'être protégé contre les
attaques donc concrètement aujourd'hui
sur les voies intercommunal saint
quentin en yvelines l'éclairage est un
éclairage à led intelligent qui permet
de s'adapter à distance et qui est
piloté avec un humain derrière qui
permet de contrôler le niveau
d'intensité voilà quelques-unes des
technologies justement pourquoi les
utilisent et quels sont les objectifs
pour pour saint quentin en yvelines les
objectifs c'est bien sûr de répondre au
développement durable aussi à consommer
mieux ah et puis de mettre l'usager au
centre effectivement du développement
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
important dans le cloud intelligent ça
permet assez facilement aussi à des
personnes
effectivement handicapés aussi de
pouvoir se mouvoir avec des technologies
particulières et on vous en parliez on
va parler aussi des projets 1 qui sont à
venir qui pourraient émerger sur le
territoire et cette annonce de valérie
pécresse le 18 mars dernier et qui a
évoqué un projet de cyber caserne
régional qui ouvrirait à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur ce projet on
est très fier avant nous portons ce
projet là avec d'autres territoires
notamment lille et l'idée c'est vraiment
d'avoir une équipe de personnes qui peut
agir sur trois choses donc cette fameuse
cybercases 1 pour vraiment voir ça comme
une caserne de pompiers en fait les
pompiers frontale un travail formidable
ils sont à la fois là sur la prévention
en nous expliquant comment faire en
sorte d'éviter le feu donc pareil il ya
cette notion de veille qui permet
effectivement de donner des bons
conseils et aussi d'intervenir quand la
menace est là quand le système est à
quai quand il ya des villes
malheureusement qui se sont fait hacker
et il y avait plus de services aux
habitants donc un petit peu d des
ingénieurs qui viennent réparer ça et
qui vais faire en sorte effectivement
que ça ne se reproduise pas cette cyber
caserne régional est vraiment des
liasses c'est très novateur on est très
fier de l'avoir sur sur saint quentin en
yvelines ça devrait se développer dans
l'année prochaine et vous le disiez un
rayonnement régional du coup pour cet
hiver caserne à rayonnement régional
mais on travaille étroitement avec l'île
de france donc on sera pilote pour l'île
de france semblait très fier
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
est importante et l'histoire
d'innovation d'en parler à saint quentin
en yvelines on est complètement dedans
dernière chose mais vous l'avez dit a
priori l'année prochaine pour voir
émerger ce projet absolument avec
peut-être un autre système porté par
seine yvelines numériques qui est
hébergé sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines on parlait du
système du socle fameux système qui
permet de pouvoir détecter des attaques
malveillantes pour pour ses usagers donc
sur le territoire des yvelines où des
hauts-de-seine aussi en avril 2000 2022
une minute à peu près sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines en matière
de cybersécurité on sait qu'il ya de
grands groupes et aussi des pme qui sont
implantés et qui parlent de cette
thématique y aussi l'école de 1600 qui
est bien va former sur les métiers de la
cybersécurité l'objectif pour
l'agglomération le disais tout à l'heure
être initiateur dans ce domaine
complètement aujourd'hui il manque à peu
près 3000 postes de qui touche à la
cybersécurité on a besoin de former on a
la chance d'avoir fait venir l'école de
1600 qui est la première école 100%
dédié pour former les gens à la
cybersécurité il recrute c'est gratuit
ces fonctionnaires en fonction de
l'apprentissage il recrute à bac + 2 ils
sont 75 la première promo et ils vont
jusqu'au master donc on essaie aussi de
se doter des outils de formation qui
permettent de répondre aux demandes
croissantes des entreprises merci
bertrand cocarde est revenue en plateau
et je rappelle que vous êtes vice
présidente saint-quentin-en-yvelines
délégué à la smart cities à l'énergie
public et à l'éclat légal énergie l
éclairage public et voilà j'ai remis les
mots dans le bon sens merci d'avoir été
avec nous
dans l'actualité également des chiens
héros c'est le nom de ce trophée qui est
remis tous les deux ans par la centrale
canine pour mettre en lumière ces
animaux et les honorer publiquement pour
le travail accompli au quotidien parmi
les 18 lauréats cinq chiens des pompiers
des yvelines capable de détecter des
maladies en l'occurrence le coc vie de
19 oxmo ozcan orties la ico et jean cau
ont tous été formés à la détection
olfactives au virus à l'école nationale
vétérinaire d'alfort c'est dans le val
de marne ils ont été les premiers en
france et nous avions ont pu les suivre
à l'époque vous voyez vous le voyez sur
ces images bravo à eux et également à
leurs maîtres chiens dans l'actualité
renforcer l'égalité hommes femmes dans
la vie locale c'est le principe d'une
charte européenne a été signé vendredi
dernier par françois morton le maire de
guyancourt la commune a deux ans pour
mettre en place les premiers projets
respectant lé six principes de la charte
des actions sont toutefois déjà en place
dans la commune et précision de mélanie
poker
caroline aigle été pilote de chasse la
première affectée au sein d'un escadron
de combat de l'armée de l'air et à
guyancourt la première dénomination film
nine de voix et d'équipements mis en
place par la commune depuis 2010 on a la
parité depuis 2010 voilà ça c'est une
vraie volonté politique depuis cette
époque là mais on a beaucoup par
attraper nous allons ouvrir deux salles
d'arts martiaux très prochainement nous
avions fait la demande avant les jeux
olympiques
de tokyo à
clarisse agbegnenou de bien vouloir nous
prêter son nom pour l accepter c'est
très bien d'avoir aussi
cette diversité de noms de femmes d'une
des dernières
dénomination que nous avons fait était
celle de théroigne de méricourt sur sur
le my des saules vendredi 17 septembre
guyancourt a signé la charte européenne
d'égalité hommes-femmes
la commune a deux ans pour respecter ses
engagements divers comme une
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes
l'impact sur la carrière d'agent public
mais aussi pour la vie locale
d'aiguillon courtois je crois très
fortement par exemple dans la
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans pour plein de raisons pour leur sang
pour leur sociabilisation pour leur
scolarité bien évidemment mais aussi
mais aussi parce que c'est un levier
puissant pour permettre notamment à des
femmes de reprendre une activité
professionnelle
on souhaite également maintenir ce
nombre de places en crèche important
pour une ville de notre strate et ça
aussi ce sont des leviers pour cent
guyancourt organise chaque année le
temps des femmes un mois d'animations
d'activité d'exposition la commune
espère donner rendez vous d'ici deux ans
pour évaluer les résultats
à montigny le bretonneux l'église de
saint quentin les sources a reçu
récemment yann arthus bertrand pour son
exposition là où date aussi la date
aussi c'est avant tout une lettre
envoyée par le pape françois tous les
catholiques pour alerter sur l'urgence
climatique le photographe français
grands défenseurs on le sait de la cause
environnementale a décidé et d'illustrer
certains passages de ce texte avec ses
photos et de transformer le tout en une
exposition d'une vingtaine de panneaux
les propos recueillis par antoine durand
il ya beaucoup de l'église église lire
notamment qui m'ont demandé doit avoir
des photos dont on a imprimé des jeux de
photos voilà pour moi c'est important
parce que ça porte des valeurs
essentielles qui sont des valeurs que
porte mais la religion
la bienveillance à
l'honnêteté des valeurs jeu qu'on
travaille pas assez à l'école et pas
assez en famille ouais ça sont toujours
bien partout où je vais j'aime montrer
mes photos et surtout montré les
légendes et parler de ce qui se passe
dans le monde aujourd'hui quoi mais
l'exposition se déroule jusqu'au 24
septembre elle sera ensuite observable
au cap saint jacques à aiguille en cours
du 25 septembre au 5 octobre ainsi qu'à
l'église saint-victor toujours à
guyancourt du 6 au 11 octobre le
week-end dernier c'était bien sûr les
journées européennes du patrimoine pour
l'occasion le musée d'archéologie
nationale installée à saint germain en
laye a proposé des visites pour le moins
originale il était possible de découvrir
les techniques pour sécuriser protéger
et évacuer une oeuvre en cas de
situation de crise antoine durand et
nicolas landry
en cas d'incendiés d'inondations ou de
guerre commence on protéger les oeuvres
d'un musée c'est ce qu'a décidé de
présenter le musée d'archéologie
nationale pendant les journées du
patrimoine
un vrai casse tête quand on sait que le
musée regorge de plus de 3 millions
d'oeuvres il ya des critères historiques
à stylistique scientifique histoire il
ya un sujet rare voilà donc tous ces
critères là les conservateurs vont les
examiner et vont donner un ordre pour
l'évacuation de ces objets est une
priorité c'est dans la salle piette
l'une des plus anciennes salles du musée
et surtout chargé d'histoire que se
déroule cet atelier je trouvais très
drôle de faire donc cette animation dans
la salle piette avec les vénus voilà et
de montrer avec mon collègue comment
conditionne ses oeuvres pour permettre
leur évacuation facilement sachant que
seront pas nous en cas de problème qui
évacueront que ce sont les pompiers le
déplacement de ses oeuvres d'art demande
une véritable logistique la taille le
poids mais aussi l'âge et les
restaurations fait sont à prendre en
compte avant de sécuriser et déplacé une
pièce tout est généralement conditionné
soit en caisse petit ou même très larges
ou des jarres ou des choses beaucoup
plus vaut deux dupont d re donc tout ce
qui est à sculptures en pierre tout ça
c'est aussi transporté sur palettes cet
atelier organisé uniquement durant ce
week-end a pu ravir le public et même
confirmé l'apprentissage de certains ça
a beaucoup confirmer ce que ce que je
savais ce que j'avais pu voir à travers
mes cours mais c'est vrai que là le fait
qu'ils nous ont montré sur place
vraiment le conditionnement avec le
l'emballage les oeuvres dans les mousses
dans le papier de seebach et serra ils
nous ont montré vraiment tout le
matériel et c'était très intéressant et
très très enrichissant le musée aura
trouvé son public puisque ce week-end
3200 personnes or ont déambulé entre les
murs du château de saint germain en laye
et lors de ces journées du patrimoine un
trésor se dévoilait le parc de la villa
à beauchêne au vésinet s'ouvrait au
public pendant deux jours c'est là que
vécut joséphine baker pendant 18 ans au
programme expositions et spectacle
musical pour célébrer l'artiste qui sera
portée aux nisé le 30 novembre prochain
une découverte avec mélanie poké célia
gatting au
ces de 1929 à 1947 que joséphine baker a
vécu dans cette demeure pour les
journées européennes du patrimoine la
villa beauchesne a ouvert ses portes ou
plutôt son extérieur mes visites
commentées du parc et est organisée par
les membres de la société d'histoire du
vésinet 729 ayant commencé à avoir une
certaine notoriété et certains revenus
elle a pu avec son mari de l'époque
acheté cette maison c'est quelqu'un qui
est venu habiter ici pour être
tranquille donc elle vivait au milieu de
ces animaux
un spectacle musical a eu lieu dans la
cour de la villa les visiteurs présents
ont pu également voir l'exposition
consacrée à la vie de joséphine baker
récemment j'ai lu un livre de raconter
sa vie donc j'ai découvert cette femme
que je connaissais très peu en fait et
voilà qu'on m'invite pas loin mais
c'était l'occasion de voir là où elle a
vécu un moment de sa vie dit c'est très
bien c'est super bien fait les guides
sont gentils en savent beaucoup donc
c'est agréable dans un cadre superbe
grâce à la notoriété de cette danseuse
et meneuse de revue la ville du vésinet
bénéficie d'une attractivité culturelle
la célèbre artiste est souvent mis à
l'honneur elle est mise en avant nous
lui avons donné le nom son nom sur une
salle associative
nous avons prévu aussi de donner une
option sur une place dans un des
nouveaux quartiers que nous sommes en
train de construire durant la seconde
guerre mondiale joséphine baker s'engage
dans la résistance c'est donc grâce à
son service rendu pour la nation qu'elle
entrera au panthéon le 30 novembre
prochain ce sera la première habitants
du vésinet à être pente est honni zay
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec célia gars de 100 go et
l'émission 7,8 culture si agathe son go
qui reviendra notamment sur la
réouverture du musée maurice denis c'est
à saint germain en laye belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]